ever since we took those first steps out
of the primordial soup mankind has long
since looked to the night sky and
dreamed of setting out among the stars
space is as it has been said the final
frontier the vast inky void that for all
its perils still holds a sense of wonder
and calls us to venture out and explore
the cosmos the earliest missions of the
space race during the 50s and 60s showed
the people of earth that while it wasn't
easy the dream of achieving space travel
was possible and that dream the
willingness to chase it is all you
really need to get there well that plus
a couple of friends and a volkswagen
microbus for william that dream of
traveling away from earth and up to the
starry skies was inescapable at 21 he
was a guy like many others growing up in
the 50s his friends and family all
thought of him as a bit of a beatnik who
was in deep with a lot of hip
counterculture types william had even
dabbled in a few alternative religious
groups as well most notably practices
like the action of transcendental
meditation as well as the teachings of
meher baba an indian spiritual leader
who claimed to be god in human form in
other words william would have been a
full-blown hippie in the 60s if he'd
only lived long enough to see them even
now the idea of taking a summer road
trip with a small group of close friends
isn't unheard of and that's almost
exactly what william had in mind during
the summer of 1958 but with a few key
differences for one this was set to be a
one-way road trip with zero plans for a
return journey and why you guessed it it
was because william and his pals wanted
to go to outer space more specifically
they wanted to drive to space to leave
the world behind and cruise all the way
out into the shining lights of the solar
system in march william bought a brand
new microbus a volkswagen type 2 zomba
bus after pooling money for a down
payment with his three friends jerry sam
and susan ask anyone nowadays to picture
an old school minivan and they'd
probably end up describing the exact
same type of bus what had spurred them
to buy a bus in the hopes of traveling
off-world in it well the three had
recently been excommunicated from the
fifth church a highly secretive new age
religion members of the church or
fifthists are all about conformity and
control you may remember these eccentric
folks from our video on
scp-3512 the more you know but william's
intention of traveling to space seemed
to conflict with the fifth church's
beliefs most likely on account of his
free spirit defying a group whose two
main hobbies were obsessing over
patterns and mind control the young man
believed there was magic up there among
the stars and refused to work a boring
9-5 waiting for that magic to come down
to earth so with the help of jerry he
began to work on modifying the bus
heaven was up there and according to
william it was waiting for its angels it
took about two months but jerry came
through the engine compartment and cabin
of the microbus were now airtight with
the section near the rear doors
transformed into an air lock the windows
were replaced with shatterproof acrylic
the outer surface treated to withstand
any space debris the gas tank had been
replaced with technology decades ahead
of its time but the steering wheel gear
shift handbrake and pedals all
functioned exactly the same one look at
the outer panels of the microbus would
have told you what it was and where it
was heading the word starmobile was
spray painted on one side and the other
alpha centauri or bust the fourth of
july rolled around and their star mobile
took flight william keeping a diary of
their journey referred to himself and
his friends as the only four people in
the universe who were truly free
careening upwards at 82 miles per hour
without any police to stop them no
longer restricted by mundane life on
earth the group traveled higher and
higher in their microbus their plan was
to travel straight to alpha centauri the
closest star and planetary system to our
own solar system thinking their journey
would only last a few short weeks
william and his friends waved farewell
to earth the bus had everything on board
that these intergalactic travelers could
possibly need from bed rolls and pillows
to sleep on to enough dehydrated food to
feed the four of them for three whole
months in space there was even room
aboard the microbus for susan's cat
milly as well as all the comforts of
home william and his friends packed
bongos a guitar and countless books but
this road trip wasn't just an aimless
joyride out into the cosmos the intrepid
group had enough supplies with them and
enough ambition to set up the first
off-world human colony they'd packed a
seed bank containing hundreds if not
thousands of varying seeds from a number
of common domestic plants from earth on
top of that there were even frozen egg
cells of domestic animals like cats and
dogs and livestock such as cows and pigs
these embryos were all ready to be
unfrozen and allowed to grow once the
gang reached their destination however
it didn't take long for problems to
start arising for one the group quickly
ran out of libations within the first
five days of leaving earth spirits were
naturally dampened by the absence of
spirits but william tried to remain
optimistic hoping to grow barley and
concoct some homemade brew once they
arrived at alpha centauri but while the
lack of ale and lager was an
inconvenience there was worse on the
horizon during a group sing-along
something collided with the star mobile
naturally all aboard were rattled and it
was jerry who stepped up to calm
everyone stating it was likely just
space dust or debris he opted to take a
look outside and see if there had been
any damage to the microbus donning a
homemade spacesuit jerry left via the
airlock at the rear of the bus and
examined finding no significant harm had
been done but as he was about to make
his way back inside something struck the
starmobile again the force of it caused
jerry to lose his grip sending him
drifting out into space william was the
only one at the wheel of the bus but had
never learned to drive eventually he was
able to turn the samba bus around but it
was too late
jerry was dead adrift in the cold vacuum
the loss overwhelmed the group but hit
susan worst of all she and jerry had
wanted to get married the moment they
arrived at alpha centauri william had
even obtained a minister's license so he
could officiate his friend's wedding
that would now never happen three days
later sam and william awoke to find
susan dead on the floor of the bus the
grief and sorrow had gotten too much for
her according to william's diary she
died of a broken heart drawing up his
guitar and strumming amazing grays for
his second dead friend william watched
as sam let susan's body drift out of the
airlock he wrote in his journal that he
hoped she would find jerry out there in
space and at least they would be
together by now it had been well over 50
days since the starmobile had left the
safe confines of planet earth the group
had suffered two tragic heartbreaking
casualties already one by accident and
one as a result of the first and yet
william and sam the survivors were still
traveling even deeper into the dark void
above plotting their chorus to alpha
centauri as best they could with the
hand-drawn star charts they had brought
with them so far their journey into
space had begun with promise and
optimism and was now fraught with
dangers and obstacles and these were far
from over slowly william began to
realize that it was taking much longer
to reach their destination than he and
jerry had first anticipated alpha
centauri is roughly four and a half
light years from earth bear in mind that
a single light year is equivalent to
roughly six trillion miles william was
unsure if the microbus had been
traveling in the right direction or if
it had even managed to miss the terminus
of the journey the charts jerry had
drawn were of little help he had been
the expert the one who planned the trip
and modified the volkswagen type 2 zomba
bus for space travel william was out of
his depth hurtling through the galaxy
with little help from his passenger to
make matters worse both william and sam
had started feeling unwell not just
travel sick as you might expect after
spending a long ride in the microbus
trundling through space their illness
wasn't even caused by being trapped in
the cramped space for such a long
duration of time blotches had begun to
appear all over their skin and sam had
been having trouble eating at random
even a tooth spontaneously fell out of
his mouth these aren't symptoms typical
of space travel though due to a severe
lack of vitamin c in the food they had
packed the pair of them had developed
scurvy just as it seemed like a trip to
alpha centauri couldn't have been a
bigger disaster william awoke to see
something out of the microbus window
something he had probably seen hundreds
of times in his lifetime but seeing it
now filled him with dread it was the
moon as in
earth's moon they were barely close to
alpha centauri quickly realizing that
they would never reach their destination
on their current course due to their
grievous errors in calculation william
did the only thing he could he closed
the curtains so that sam couldn't see
how big of a mistake they had made
eventually milly crawled behind the sofa
and died meanwhile sam stopped being
able to keep his food down towards the
end he could barely so much as see or
even sit every time he asked his friend
if they had arrived yet william would
tell him that they would be there
tomorrow he couldn't bring himself to
tell sam the truth finally sam asked
william to read to him a poem by dylan
thomas called and death shall have no
dominion he was dead before william
finished reading saddened and filled
with remorse william pushed the last of
his friends out of the airlock realizing
that no one would be left to push him
out whenever he eventually died the
final thought he recorded in his diary
came after two whole months spent
isolated and alone in space before
william's death the last thing he wrote
was that the stars looked so beautiful
against the dark backdrop of the
universe in spite of the tragedy of his
situation so few others especially from
his time would ever truly see them like
this today the bus is still drifting
quietly through space now known as
scp-1958 it rests in the orbit of mars
the withered remains of its driver still
sitting at the wheel william and his
friends never made it to alpha centauri
in fact it would have taken them almost
40 million years to reach it they never
saw their dream come to the ending that
they had planned instead william jerry
sam susan and millie the cat all died
among the stars driving their magic bus
their star mobile out into the unknown
for them space that final frontier had a
lot more finality to it now go check out
how not to kill an scp
scp-1609 remains of a chair and
scp-701 the hanged king's tragedy for
more anomalies that veer into the tragic